so therefore we're under the heading you
know how do you study how do you
rehearse well you've got to you've got
to do math
right so that leads me to this question
let me walk you through first this is um
i know what's special about mathematics
okay
my first tip for you is how do you do
exercises because the point is you must
right well here's a pretty typical
exercise i've pulled out of a textbook
okay
here's my first tip for you okay
your teacher says okay do this many
questions right and you're like okay
i'll give it a go but you know i've got
i've got things to do at home i've got
things to move on with i've got other
assignments that i gotta
work on you know so you're like i
probably it might take like an hour
to finish this right like this this
looks like hard kind of stuff
right and i've only really got 15
minutes okay so you think no problem
i'll get as far as i can in 15 minutes
you're like oh three minutes
four minutes three minutes five minutes
but okay you get to here and you stop
and you have to because let's face it
how many seriously how many subjects do
you do the rest of um
ten nine yeah that's a lot to keep in
your brain
right can you imagine talking to a
sportsman right
and i'm like yeah how's your um how's
your how's your forearm going in tennis
right
and he's like oh i've been a bit busy
trying to work on my basketball and
you're like
what kind of sportsman are you right so
what you guys are doing
learning all these different things
simultaneously is quite astonishing
but it leads to promising problems like
this okay so here's my first tip for you
don't don't do that don't do that if you
only got 15 minutes fine
okay but don't do these questions or
don't do just these questions can anyone
tell me
why might that be a bad idea just doing
the first five questions on there yeah
right in fact you can even sort of see
like the way it's laid out just take a
step back
you don't have to do this imagine you
were writing this thing
right as a textbook writer you're trying
to give people
exercises meat to practice on right so
you give them a whole bunch of questions
that are very similar
right you can see these are quite
similar and these are quite similar
that's why they're grouped up
in these kinds of sections right so can
anyone suggest to me
what might be a better alternative than
just doing these five
being that if you want to get it you do
have to practice yeah
yeah so here's there you go maybe you
want to jot that down instead of
just focusing at the top which by the
way not just on one style of question
but almost invariably will be the
easiest kinds of questions because we're
kind of
trying to warm you up as you're getting
into an exercise
here's the way i would say distribute
the amount of the number of questions
that you do
okay do some from here some from here
some from here some from here do some
from the beginning
some from the end right if you're like i
can only do two questions in each
section
don't just do a and b because they'll be
the easiest ones right
maybe do b and f and that'll really give
you a workout